Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 20, where we're going to talk about arrays, pointers, and algorithms.
So let's talk about pointers and arrays. The array name represents the address of the first element.
So in the array ar here, ar is really not a separate variable, it's just the address of 1.
I can store that address into a pointer like this. So I can say i_ptr = the address of ar sub 0.
However, since the array name is the address of the first element, I can also say i_ptr = ar. That's much easier.
It's not ok to take the address of that address. So i_ptr = the address of ar is not ok.
Now, i_ptr does not need to point to the first element. If I want to point it to the second element, I can say i_ptr = the address of ar sub 1.
However, while I can change what's in this pointer variable, I cannot change what's in ar.
So I cannot say ar = i_ptr and have ar now change so it's pointing to the second element.
So ar is like a constant pointer to the first element of the array.
So think of an array name as a pointer literal.
Now, you can access elements using the subscript operator. So here's array ar sub 0.
We call this array notation.
With a pointer, we can access it using the indirection operator. This is called pointer notation. So see out *ipointer.
However, that's just convention. In fact, you can use both the subscript operator and the indirection operator indiscriminately.
So on ar, if I wanted to print out the first element, I could say *ar.
On my pointer, *ipointer p, if I wanted to print out the element it's pointing at, I could say pointer sub 0.
That's because all address expressions simply combine an address and an offset.
So address bracket offset means the same as add the offset to the address and dereference it.
So these two expressions are entirely identical.
Now, given this, so I have an array ar, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I have an int n and an int m, 1 and 2.
If I say ar sub 3, it gets me the value 4.
ar sub 0, ar sub 1, ar sub 2, ar sub 3.
This is array notation and I'm using literals.
If I add ar plus 3, that gives me a new address.
So ar is pointing here, ar plus 1 is pointing there, ar plus 2 is pointing there, and ar plus 3 is pointing there.
And I dereference that pointer, or that address, using address arithmetic, I still get the 4.
I could use ar plus 3, again so I've taken the pointer ar, which is pointing to 1, moved it 1, 2, and 3.
I've offset it by 3.
And then, instead of dereferencing it, I could subscript it at 0.
So the element at that 0 dereference it.
I could do ar plus 1, ar pointing to the 1, ar plus 1 pointing to the 2.
And then I could substripe it with m. That means add 1, 2 to the address and dereference it.
So all of these things, all of these expressions, would give me this value 4.
So subscripting and pointer notation are just two ways to do the same thing.
So when I say I pointer plus 1, this is a pointer plus an integer expression.
This is an address expression. You know if you add an integer and a double, you get back a double?
If you add a pointer and an integer, you get back a pointer.
The int in this case represents an offset, but not a byte offset.
It doesn't mean go forward one byte from I pointer.
It means go forward one element.
What's an element? The element is the number of bytes based on the element's type.
So if I pointer is an int, generally this is going to be the same as taking this address and adding 4 to that address
because we're adding the size of one int.
So here's some equivalent expressions.
ar, of course, is the address of ar sub 0.
ar plus 1 is the address of ar sub 1.
star ar plus 1 is equal to ar sub 1
and star ar plus 1 is equal to ar sub 0 plus 1.
Now, since the array names are constant, they can't be changed,
but a pointer that points to an array element may be changed.
This is really important when you're using the plus plus and minus minus operators.
Remember that these operators are right associative.
That means that when we increment a pointer, the operator that's to the right is going to happen first.
So assume that we have an array 10 and a pointer that points to that array.
If I do this, star ar plus plus, that's illegal.
In other words, I can't apply the plus plus to the ar because ar is an array.
Star i pointer plus plus is fine.
That means it's right associative, so we increment first and then dereference.
Now, because this is post increment, however,
the value of this expression, i pointer plus plus, is what pointer was pointing to before it was changed.
So this moves the pointer, returns the old pointer, and that old pointer is then dereferenced.
This also is fine. Here we're incrementing the pointer,
and now we're returning the new pointer and we're dereferencing it.
OK, let's look at arrays, functions, and pass by address.
Now, arrays are passed to functions by address, not by reference.
It's similar to pass by reference, but it's a little bit different.
So here is a function called sum that takes an array a and a size.
Remember, when we call a function, we have to pass the size because we don't copy that.
Now, the parameter a here is really a pointer.
It's a pointer that's initialized with the address of the first element in the array when the array is called.
And we can write it like that with the empty brackets. That's perfectly fine.
That kind of tells the people who see the parameter that you're expecting to see an array there.
Or it can be written the way you'd write a regular pointer, int star a.
Both of those are perfectly fine.
And this is the only place these two notations are interchangeable,
when you have a parameter that's pointing to an array.
Unlike a vector, you cannot pass an array by value.
You cannot pass an array by value.
So we're going to look at this. I think it's useful to see this visually.
So I'm going to run a...I'm going to try and run a thing.
Let's see if this will pop up. Yes, it popped up.
I'm going to bring this over here and maximize it over here.
So here's a little function where I create an array. I'm going to go to the first here.
I create an array. When I initialize it, it's initialized on the stack to 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Now I'm going to call this function sum.
You notice that it takes an argument, an array, a, and the length,
and it's simply going to loop through that array and sum the element.
So watch what happens when I call sum.
So we have to create what's called a stack frame.
Notice that the parameter a is a pointer to const.
So a is a pointer, length is a size t, result is a local variable.
And these, of course, are all created on the stack.
Now as we go through, notice that a is pointed to that array.
So we haven't passed the array, we've passed the pointer.
And as we loop through here, it goes through and just adds the values.
And finally it's going to return the result.
We're going to print the result 15 out here when we're done,
and that stack frame is going to be destroyed.
So the effect of doing that is similar to pass by reference.
And so we always, but notice we don't use the ampersand with the array parameter at all.
Again, don't get confused with that.
Now if the array is not changed, like we did in our sum function,
then make sure you put the const in front of the parameter.
If you don't put the const, then we cannot pass a constant array to the function,
which is something we'd want to do for summing.
Okay, we're going to finish up by looking at some essential algorithms.
Common algorithms are similar to vector.
Of course we have to deal differently with the size problem, right?
We can't simply write one and get the size out of the argument.
Also, since there's no range checking, we have to spend extra care to make sure we're doing it correct.
So let's do three or four algorithm exercises similar to the ones we did before.
So our first one is we're going to count for a particular condition.
So let's go over to our handout here.
So our first exercise, we're going to write two array counting functions, count evens and word founds.
Once you've written the stubs for minimal functions, then build using make test.
Once you can build, then you complete the bodies for each function.
So let's go over here.
This is going to be in 20A in our IC folder.
So here's counting.cpp.
We're going to write our two functions here, count evens.
So that's going to return the count of even numbers, so int count evens.
Numbers is an array of int, so const int numbers, bracket bracket.
And length is the size of the array. I'll use size T.
And we're going to create the result, so int sum.
And I'm going to return that sum.
Let me call it actually count because it's count even.
Okay, we're doing the stub first.
Okay, our second function is word found.
It's going to return the number of times that word is found in the array strings.
So strings is an array of string to be searched.
It's going to return an int, words found.
And so an array of strings, so const string bracket bracket strings.
So strings is the name of the array.
And word is a string, so it's a const string reference word.
So notice how I used the reference here on the individual string,
but I don't use the reference here at all.
Okay, so let's say int found is zero and return found.
So now we have a good stub. Let's create a folder here.
Let's try it, make test.
Now we know that it compiles. No.
Okay, so this is a problem with people who come from Java.
In Java we could write the array like that.
In C++, remember that the brackets need to go after the name of the variable,
not after the name of the type.
And I actually haven't programmed Java for a couple years,
and I still constantly make that mistake.
Okay, words found.
Okay, so that means I, so this is a linker error, words found,
that means me think I spelled the name wrong. No.
Hmm, okay. Let's look at these.
I passed only two parameters, forgot the third parameter.
Okay, let's try that again.
Make test.
Okay, and our code compiles now correctly.
So we have the stub correct.
Okay, so now let's go over algorithm for counting.
It's the same as it was for vectors.
Create a variable to hold the counter.
So I'm counting over here the number of even numbers found in the array.
We'll use four, size p, i, equals zero, i less than len.
Notice I don't have to get len out of size like I would with a vector.
Plus plus i, and if numbers sub i, remainder two is zero,
then we're going to increase our counter, count plus plus.
Okay, let's try that before we go on to the next one.
So let's do make test.
And some of these are not working.
Actually, none of those are working.
Oh yeah, count evens is working now.
I was looking up earlier in the test.
Count evens is working.
Alright, let's just clear that.
So that is working.
I'm not sure why this -- I'm not sure why that's printing twice like that.
That's kind of strange.
Okay, and let's do words found.
So we'll do the same thing.
Four, size p, i, equals zero, i less than len, plus plus i, if strings sub i equals word.
And we found another one, found plus plus, and we're going to return found.
Okay, so the algorithm is not hard, just the different mechanics for --
so we have 100% now.
The different mechanics for working with an array are different.
Okay, so we did counting.
Now let's go ahead and do accumulating.
So we're going to do adding, our second one here.
So on adding, we're going to write the function sum13,
and I'm going to assume I'm going to kill both these terminals here.
And I'm going to kill that.
I'm going to go to b.
And I'm going to put my id on here.
And here's the instructions for the function.
Add the numbers in the array, except the number 13 and the numbers immediately following don't count.
So it's an integer array, so my sum is going to be an int, sum13.
It's going to take a const int numbers, bracket, bracket.
Now remember we could write this as this way, but still work exactly the same way.
And size t, len, and int sum is zero.
Return sum.
And we got the stub.
We probably should make sure we have a terminal here.
And do make test on it.
So our stub works okay.
And so let's look at the algorithm for adding.
Again we go through each element in the array.
For size t, i equals zero, i less than len, plus plus i.
And if numbers sub i is not equal to 13, then we want to add it.
Let's say sum plus equals, not plus plus, sum plus equals numbers sub i.
Now what if it is equal to 13? Do we want to do anything?
Well we don't want to add it, but we need to skip the next one.
So I'm going to need to have another plus plus i here, so I skip that number immediately following.
So I don't print that.
Okay, so now let's try it once again.
Make test.
And now we have 100% of it.
The third algorithm we want is we want to find the extreme values, the largest and the smallest ones.
So let's close that terminal. Let's close adding.
Let's go to extreme.
Here we're going to write the function big diff.
So we're going to print the difference between the smallest and largest elements in numbers.
So the difference is going to be an int.
Function is named big diff.
And it's going to take const int numbers, it's an array, and size p len.
And so rather than creating a result here, what we're going to do is walk through the algorithm for finding the largest and smallest.
So int largest equals numbers sub zero.
Int smallest equals numbers sub zero.
So the largest and smallest are the first element in the array.
Now we're going to look through the rest of the elements.
So we're going to print for size p i equals, we've already looked at zero, right?
One, i less than len, plus plus i.
And now for each number we're going to see if the number we have here at numbers sub i is greater than the largest or smaller than the smallest.
So if numbers sub i is greater than the largest, then the largest is numbers sub i.
We're changing largest.
And if numbers sub i is less than the smallest, then the smallest equals numbers sub i.
Now could both of these be true?
No, both of those couldn't be true.
As long as we have a value of smallest and largest, then both of these couldn't be true.
Okay, now we're done.
And so we need to figure out what we're going to return, the difference between the largest and smallest.
And so we're going to say return largest minus smallest.
We don't need the absolute value because that will always be zero or greater.
Zero or greater.
Okay, let's open a shell on that and try it out.
Make test.
Alright, that's good.
Now we're going to test out one more thing here.
And that is returning an array.
So you can't return a local array, unlike a vector.
However, the effect of pass by address is exactly the same as pass by reference.
And so you can use that to create array output parameters.
So here's an example.
We want to use a loop to fill an array with a value.
You can't just write a function that returns an array.
So what you have to do is you have to pass the array in.
Notice we're missing the const in front of it.
It says this is either an input/output or an output parameter.
And this is going to fill this entire array with this value.
So notice while length is not equal to zero, that's a shorthand way to say that.
A and then minus minus len, because len of course is going to be beyond the last index.
So that's going to put it to the last index equals value.
Now len is shorter, but it isn't yet zero yet.
When len is one, minus minus len is going to say a sub zero equals value.
We'll come over here.
While len, len is zero. That's false.
And the loop will end.
Okay, so let's do our last exercise here.
Output.cpp
Let's close that shell. Let's close that.
Let's go into D.
And put our ID on this.
So here we're going to write a void function, a procedure.
So void ten run.
It's going to take an array, numbers.
So int numbers, that is modified in the function.
Notice I didn't do constant numbers.
Size, p, len.
Void functions are really easy to stub.
So we can go ahead and create a shell on that now.
Open it in the integrated terminal.
I do make test.
And you can see that it runs.
It doesn't give us the correct answer, of course.
So here's our algorithm.
We want to look at the numbers, and for each multiple of ten,
change all the values following it to be that multiple of ten,
until encountering another multiple of ten.
So here's the first one. Two, multiple of ten, don't do anything to it.
Ten, multiple of ten, remember it.
Three, not a multiple of ten, change it to ten.
Four, not a multiple of ten, change it to ten.
Twenty, another multiple of ten, remember it.
Five, change it to twenty.
So for this, we're going to do for size, p, i equals zero, i less than len, plus plus i.
If numbers sub i, remainder ten equals zero.
So that's a multiple of ten, right?
It's evenly divisible by ten.
If that's true, what we want to do is remember it.
If that's false, we want to store remembered value in numbers sub i.
So how do I remember something?
I remember something by storing it in a variable.
So let's say int remembered equals zero.
Alright, yeah, let's just say int remembered equals zero.
So if that's the case, we're going to say remembered equals numbers sub i.
And now we're going to store the remembered value in numbers sub i.
So numbers sub i equals remembered.
Okay, let's try it and see if that works.
It kind of looks like it should work.
Let's move this over here so we can see the whole test.
Make test.
Oh, I got 50%.
So let's look at what's expected here.
So ten run gives me two, ten, ten, ten, twenty, twenty.
So I'm expected to ten, ten, twenty, twenty.
So this is what it's expected to be out of that.
But I found zero ten, ten, ten, twenty, twenty.
So it looks like this first number is not a multiple of ten.
And I replace it with the remembered value.
And my remembered value here is zero.
So it looks like this store the remembered value only works if I've already seen a multiple of ten.
So we could create a flag in there and say, you know, yes, I saw a multiple of ten and set it.
Or we could use a special flag value like that and then say, if remembered is not equal to minus one,
then numbers of i equals remembered.
So we have to handle the case, we have to make sure that we're not doing anything until we've already seen one already.
When we do that, we should go from 50% to 100% now.
All of them should work.
Alright, folks, it looks like that is all we have today.
When you come back, I'll see you in the next lecture in lecture 21.